Hello.
Nice to see you again.
Thanks for joining us today on this
very,
very special episode of the HD podcast.
No Man's left behind.
Uh,
first of all,
let me welcome you all
under the Gazebo.
Today on a very special podcast,
we'll be joined by kid,
the producer and the intern isla.
The pregnant
no means left behind today.
We are sponsored by skill share.
Now let me explain what is going on
today.
Okay.
Throughout the year we've covered a lot
of stories.
We've talked about a lot of things,
but there's always these great goofs
laughs and gaffs and boobs even.
I would even venture to say a couple of
booths that fall through the crack.
They're great,
but we just didn't have time to get to
them.
And so we've asked Dan and Ian and Isla
and even myself to go through all of our
documents over the course of the past
year and to salvage to save our fallen
meme brothers who have fallen behind
enemy lines.
And we've said,
no,
these are fresh,
these are spooky.
These deserve to be aired.
And so that is what we are here to do
today.
So today,
no me will be left behind.
And uh,
that's it.
So Ian and,
uh,
and Dan,
would you join us please in the,
uh,
in the office here in the studio?
So introducing a dam
of course.
Yes.
Round of applause as a couple of God
dammit.
Join us if you would please.
Thank you so much.
Now Dan is
now,
how long have you guys been with this?
Uh,
let's see.
It was a,
what was your first episode?
The first episode was a,
you know what the first episode was,
Joey Salads?
I think so.
How was that as like an introduction?
You were,
I don't know if you were fans of us,
but you knew who we were.
Yeah,
no,
I was a fan.
I watched the show or the,
the main channel,
uh,
pretty regularly,
so I knew Joey Salads and that was
definitely,
that was definitely a weird thing to
step into.
But I think the second week with Steevo,
which was fucking awesome to get to meet
him.
So that was,
that was a good introduction.
Dan,
the producer we cherish and love.
We were a bit of a mess here.
And Dan was like a great recommendation
from somebody through twitch.
Right?
Yeah.
And so we're like,
dude,
do you want to just work full time?
It was like,
well yeah.
And uh,
the rest has been history as they say.
And we're just,
Oh,
about a year ago,
well it was even longer.
Um,
summer.
It was summer of 2017 so yeah,
so there you go.
Time flies,
man.
Seriously,
I'm flying.
That's crazy actually.
And Ian,
of course,
the illustrious,
uh,
I want to say the eternal intern.
Oh,
I reached to us has a
great origin story.
Ian.
Ian Was Richard not to us even before we
hired then.
I think both.
You didn't have to even follow up with
him.
Well,
I've probably,
I've probably told the story a couple of
times,
but it bears being repeated because it's
such a great cause that we get a lot of
emails from people and our,
you know,
we have a work with h three email that's
open to the general public.
We've got a lot of requests,
a lot of emails.
But Ian comes through very respectable,
very eloquent.
And he says,
Hey,
you know what,
I would like to be an intern for you.
And uh,
you must've emailed us like 20 times.
Like shawshank redemption.
Like remember when he was writing the
letter asking for library funds?
That was,
yeah,
fair.
I kept telling him keep checking in with
us cause I know we'll need help,
but we can't do it right now,
but we will.
So,
and were you a fan of ours am yeah.
Yeah,
it was.
I really,
yeah,
yeah.
I really kind of harassed you guys.
I was basically,
you know,
just,
bothering it nonstop.
I worked out.
Now was that a technique I have to ask,
what were you reading?
Other people's similar emails because
you had a strategy and I'm wondering
other people were,
you know,
not rallying out.
Not really actually,
because you know,
you guys were,
were the most open,
you know,
a lot of people just,
trash,
recycle this email.
So,
you know,
you guys were open,
like you said,
you said keep trying.
So,
you know,
you kept at it.
Well that's a good life lesson for all
the people out there.
That persistence is truly the key to
either success or prison depending on
how weird you are fighting your case.
Success restraining order.
Yeah.
One or the other.
That's good to know the difference.
But not all of us have that gift.
And Ian,
I want to say a,
it has been a treat,
a pleasure,
a joy we love and so much,
God bless [inaudible] intern.
He's not really an intern anymore.
He's blossomed into so much more.
My first episode was when skippy and
John's miss.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I wanted to come into,
wow.
I feel like things have like tamed since
you guys started.
We got to get back into doing some more
weird and wild stock.
But um,
those were the days persuaded Joey
Salads and over a year,
well,
I'm looking forward to our Christmas
special this 21st.
Right.
We're going to do another chair.
Do you?
Christmas special.
Oh,
well,
okay.
Well yeah,
we're doing it with Justin Roy Lynn,
Alex Hirsch and Dana terrorists.
Terrorists sang it,
right?
That's right.
Yeah,
I think you're right.
I don't,
I blanked.
But anyway,
and Joey Salads,
so we're trying to think how can we,
you know,
involve Joey Salads in this?
And we were thinking,
well we already pepper sprayed him.
Maybe we can shoot them with a nonlethal
bein bad.
I don't know.
That'd be fine.
And of course justin will have to be the
one that pulled the trigger.
They'll repeat though the 21st mark it
down on the calendars.
Boys.
We're going to do all a lot of good this
year.
And that would be the last episode
before I will say yes.
Yes.
Well guys,
I'm here.
We are gathered today at the podcast
table and um,
we have a lot of,
yeah.
How does it feel being in here?
Do you guys like being in here or do you
not like being in here?
It's,
I dunno,
I definitely prefer to be behind the
scenes,
but it's okay.
Ian,
do you like your airtime?
Oh,
I'm having a panic attack.
I'm not like,
you like the air.
I think I'm a camera hog.
You're not buttoned up.
I know him means a hog.
What I mean,
you know,
you,
you're,
you have a presence on camera.
Yeah.
You have a natural charisma.
I always think that he,
and he was like more like me.
It's subtle.
It's subtle panic attack.
I'll slow keep it together,
but still,
I mean I don't mind it.
Sure.
Yeah.
You love it.
Lamb,
that handle of whiskey right before we
came in here,
holding it down,
that's the case.
So we have together,
um,
I will go first.
I have what I call it,
the Turkish food segment and this is one
that I have personally been working on
for a long time and you guys have been
kind of working along with me to collect
these videos.
The whole world out there on instagram.
I was browsing the explore tab and you
know,
they've got this algorithm,
so when you click one video then they
know to show you more like it.
And I started watching these incredible
Turkish chefs doing stuff that I've
never seen done with food before.
And I went down this crazy rabbit hole
of Turkish instagram cooking some
amazing,
some disgusting,
some hilarious.
It's about at all.
And I'm,
and I'm passionate about this and I
watched this to this day.
In fact,
I saw one this morning that I'd like to
open up with that was completely,
completely confused by it.
And maybe you guys can tell me what is
this.
So tell me,
what is this?
I don't know what it is.
It looks like a penis.
He says Penis White,
Clara frying open.
What looks like a Oregon.
God,
is that like a bull?
But it looks like it's like dry flower
coming out of this.
I mean,
I don't know what on earth while I was
curious.
So I translated the description and
it always goes great.
And um,
I'll read it for you guys here today.
No,
I'm Turkish name that.
I've never seen anything like the
translation for 16 months and tripe
belly fat cheese open and tasted for the
wildlife.
It was quite heavy and couldn't even
stand the smell,
but a very special and delicious cheese.
Um,
in general,
the families for consumption at home
such as pressing out the room and we're
not coincide.
I,
yeah,
this gets,
no,
that clears it all.
It just says wildlife but not what I,
animal barely fats.
Well it sounds like it was fermented and
an actual belly,
but I love this line.
I couldn't even stand the smell.
Very special.
Yeah.
So there you have.
But would that being said,
let's jump right into this Turkish food.
Let's see what we have here.
So one thing I've noticed,
because in Israel obviously there's
rules of kosher,
which means you cannot mix meat and
cheese.
But the Turks almost in a way of being
like sucks to be Jewish.
They go all out on the cheese and meat.
Like even in America I've never seen
before.
It would take a look at this.
I thought they were kosher in,
in Turkey as well.
Well it's,
hello Dan is what it's called and they
actually,
hello?
You can mix meat and cheese.
They cannot drink alcohol,
but they are not,
they share a lot of the similarities.
Like they don't eat pig.
Right?
Right.
Yeah.
But they plant food and shellfish.
Shellfish.
Yeah.
Huh.
But they can do the dairy and the meat.
And so they are like,
God bless them.
They took their like praise be to a law.
We're going all out.
But that's dairy and meat.
Yeah.
As you should so happy.
I never,
first of all,
what is this whole method of cooking is
bananas to me so that he cooked it and
like a pile of sand.
Whoa.
He takes out this unbelievably tender
rack of ribs,
loved the music management,
Spiderman and elsewhere.
Those bones slide right out.
I mean this is a incredibly beautifully
cut piece of meat.
Now here's where it gets insane.
I don't know what this is,
but he took a what looks like 10 pounds
of cheese and put it on top 10 pounds of
cheese on top and just without any grief
at all,
that's it in half.
I mean,
look,
sprinkles a little good measure.
Imagine that.
I'll tell you something right now.
I will eat though.
He had had,
sure you are kind of obsessed with this
videos.
Does it tell you about that end?
I know you
guys are boring Vegans,
but why?
I mean,
did you,
uh,
have respond to that?
Did your pulse increase?
Weirdly?
I love me,
but that completely made me not hungry
at all.
The opposite thought.
Something about taking a junk,
cheesy shit on that beautifully.
It's,
I mean it's like a log of food.
I don't like eating logs if I would
definitely try that.
And you guys,
you,
you find it Apps,
I imagine not,
I dunno what's nauseous,
but I probably would be nice as from
the,
if you could feel nauseous,
it's not great.
I mean,
yeah,
I'm not Vegan so hey meet,
uh,
10 years ago.
Oh,
so it's been a minute.
I'm deep in it yet.
You've been at Dev,
you do ever feel that your will will
bray frame purpose.
Yeah,
occasionally.
And what is it attempts you?
Um,
you know,
weirdly,
uh,
seafood still is like appetizing.
Mm.
Um,
more so than a meat.
I don't know.
It's weird cause it's,
it's very much just kind of,
um,
big den after a while and certain things
like any kind of pork pig,
the smell of it is like,
it makes me almost nauseous.
Oh,
I was like so bad.
But like other meats,
like chicken,
not bad at all.
Like that's not bad.
And even beef for somebody in pork in
particular,
it's gain.
It's powerful.
Yeah.
And it's,
and it's,
uh,
somehow that the Muslims and the Jews
both were like,
we can't eat that yet.
So maybe there's something to that
maybe.
Um,
and so why did you go vegetarian Dan?
Uh,
originally,
um,
for girl that I was dating the best
reason,
absolutely.
I'm a vegetarian for a guy to go.
There you go.
Vegan for right relationship.
Really?
Oh wait,
how long are you Vegan?
Like six months,
but I started to feel very ill.
Did you immediately bounce and when you
broke up with her?
No,
I tried to keep it for a bit,
but um,
you felt you have to do it correctly.
So I was like,
oh,
well I'll just eat some cheerios cause I
don't know how to cook anything.
Right,
sure.
You know,
you got it.
You have to have like a whole plan of
meals.
Oh,
you,
you become like malnutrition.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well I look at you.
How was the,
I mean,
was it worth it for her?
Was she a good no,
no,
it wasn't even worth it.
Okay.
There.
Yeah.
The guys,
there's a good chance that you guys will
go on a diet of some point in your life
or off a diet because of some dick or a
vagina.
So there you have it.
But moving on,
this is,
we're just in,
this is just one video in to me.
I would,
Ooh.
You know,
why don't you ever take cheesy shits on
my meat?
The way he just dumped the cheese on
there?
Something breaks.
Like are the art these amazing,
like he's like,
look at these amazing slow clipped ribs.
Nope.
We're not done with it yet.
Boom.
Like seriously,
five pounds of cheese that's a slug and
looks alive.
Yeah.
Well guess what it is.
Something's moving in me,
my Dick.
Gotcha.
Cause I uh,
like it that much for that.
Thank you.
Thank you everybody.
Thank you for laughing and it's you,
me guys,
appreciate that next nobody left.
I noticed.
So this one.
So sometimes what they make such an
obscene amount of food that it,
it literally doesn't make sense.
Like I didn't even know how he uses all
this.
So a restaurant I know,
but even still like [inaudible] it is a
restaurant.
He looks like he's on the older equals.
That's true.
Wow.
Ray William Johnson took a weird twist
of Glasgow,
so he flips upside down,
was probably 20 or 30 pounds of food,
a food that frankly doesn't even look
like it belongs together.
But right off the bone,
right off the bones.
This is their mood.
They juggle it.
I know it's,
it's amazing.
Like stuffed pepper looks.
You'd hit that if it was cooked to meet
my mom cook separately.
But yeah,
so if it's cooked and me,
you're,
you're still down.
I mean,
it's a gray area.
Okay.
It's a great,
yeah.
So the volume is really kind of what
fascinates me here and having such a
good guy.
He's always smiles all the time.
Yeah.
Do you know what this guy is?
Can you like seek him out?
Yeah,
he was huge on instagram.
Is videos get like millions of views or
you got to go to Turkey someday and go
eat at this guy's from year to go to
Turkey.
They don't like Jews.
They doing,
but it's like gotten worse or they don't
like Israelis day late.
But now you can go.
I can go.
No.
As a Jew I can go get some of this meat.
How was your trip to Turkey?
It was nice.
It was like going to grace,
you know?
It's like really?
Did you see any crazy food and stuff?
Turkey's pretty sexy.
I mean it's not.
No,
it's gotten more.
Things are getting a little crazy there.
I ate regular stuff.
Nothing crazy.
Hmm.
That's a shame.
It similar to Israel.
Um,
okay,
so here you go.
That's your boy again.
All smiles sand.
I don't know what he did.
It looks like snow that he's cooking.
New Salt or salt.
Salt.
Look at this.
Look at that.
Perfect.
Look at that smile.
Look at that.
What's not to love?
This guy's a legend.
It's a beautifully,
perfectly cooked beef loins.
Okay,
but wait,
before they found out this Spiderman
Nelson music.
But wait,
my dude
I queued and Oh my God,
this was pretty normal.
Yes,
it's there.
Look at this as,
oh my goodness.
There you go.
I'm telling you these guys are way over
the top,
but the beat like I feel is almost
trolling the American crowd.
Here's what you want is,
I see.
Right,
right.
But it's Turkish people watching it.
It's not Americans is it?
I'm the only American watching this.
I swear to God.
It's all Turkish.
The comments.
Well that's what I thought too.
Everyone's like,
oh,
look at how what these Americans eat and
these Turkish people are like,
like making us look like amateur.
Yeah.
I haven't ever seen,
I'm going to stop watching porn.
Just watch when he dipped,
pours that cheese on that steak.
That's enough to get me rock hard every
time.
Um,
what else we got?
Okay,
this one is so weird,
man.
I'm wondering what you guys are going to
think about this.
So he starts with the meat.
He's got a huge hammer tank.
It's got a mallet,
like a massive hammer and a witch's
cauldron.
Oh,
he's doing this classic little shake
meat off the bone.
Yes sir.
I don't know what's on the bottom there,
but I'm down.
So now he takes it.
He's got meat and tomato paste and a
huge hammer and he's liquid eye.
He's smashed it all into it.
Looks like reefer.
I advanced.
Yeah,
it looks like our re fried beans.
I've never seen cooking like this my
whole life.
So now somehow this chicken and meat,
it's turned into a paste and he's the
line,
the bottom of the pan.
And now he's just covering it with
boiling oil.
Like if you told me there was meat in
that,
I wouldn't have no idea.
I mean,
what the hell was that?
That one has me scratching my head.
Is that wild or what?
Yeah,
I don't know what it looks like.
You could like,
it's like asphalt at the end.
He could pay for road with that,
but you start with this really succulent
beautiful meat and then you just,
I,
I then he pours oil over it like,
but that's fascinating.
Um,
we've got more.
You guys don't,
don't lose.
I don't worry.
Here's your boy.
He's the sheep king.
I think he mostly cooks lamb.
So he made this hit for all of his fans
on instagram in the world at large here.
Yes.
Everybody throw your hands up,
sees the end bora.
I love how he's like,
I'm eat fucking kid.
Throw it up y'all.
What is this?
His song,
his original fit,
but this guy's restaurant,
super famous.
Like on his instagram,
I've seen the,
the the president of Turkey.
They're only seen celebrities in his
right or the one,
yeah.
Watches instagram.
I shouldn't say,
I have no idea.
It just,
I followed it.
I don't know what it is.
Turkish.
I really don't do it.
If you type Turkish food,
he'll pop up.
He's the god Bro.
He's the God.
Look at him.
He's,
he's herding the sheep.
He's the God.
You had like a little Pied Piper thing
going on there.
Yeah.
I'm telling you,
this is a whole rabbit hole,
but I'm not done yet because all my
adventures.
Did you know that Salt Bay,
the original Salt Bay is part of the
Turkish food phenomenon,
right?
Yeah.
He is probably next to this guy.
The most famous,
his videos get so many views.
I'm talking like 12 20 million views on
instagram of him doing slapping me.
Oh,
I have another slapping the shit out of
the meat.
Oh,
I have another sheep.
God,
I sorry.
It looks like a penis.
I mean this is so wild.
Whoa.
Yeah.
This is the sheep.
God
look at it.
It was just a carcasses and a giant
sheep meat piss in the middle.
I mean,
I never seen anything like it in my
life.
She Paul,
because that's what the notch,
but it looks amazing.
I mean that's pretty awesome.
Oh yeah.
That meat is like a dozen patients is
pretty unbelievable.
The way they click it and everything is
so off the chain at some.
That one is actually on the menu as she
paul a cost and it's a very popular dish
actually in the Middle East.
Um,
I love how he,
when,
when you have like the super heavy nasty
dishes and you just sprinkle a little
like a parcel on old to make it look
fresh.
Are there,
you have it.
I don't even like your piece set that
here.
I don't know what we do.
Well,
he wasn't done.
The second part is that he puts it in a
college random beats it into a pace.
I see.
And that was,
that was a two parter.
Okay.
So back to Salt Bay.
So this I shit you not,
this video has 10 million on instagram
of Salt Bay.
Uh,
this guy,
I was kind of,
I have to say a little bit disillusioned
when I saw salt bays actual content,
because as you'll see in this video,
he does not display the best cooking
prowess that swatch.
So he has a sausage that's pretty rap
cuts.
It very dramatically feels off rapping
like he wants to fuck it.
I mean,
yeah,
now he takes a whole,
Sasha's cuts it in half.
Okay.
With it so far,
really not into it.
And he just throws it on the grill,
lapping it together.
Let's set.
Yup.
Okay.
And here's,
of course were all good.
Turkish cuisine goes tons of meat,
doesn't not spread evenly,
not even close to spread it to them.
I mean,
not even close,
like not even close.
The whole left side is no cheese.
And the right side.
It's a nice smashes it down and there
you have it,
my friend.
But that's it.
That's it.
You didn't even cook anything.
Why?
What are you doing?
And so there you have it.
And the Turkish flag.
Yeah,
that one.
I had me a little per after the lamb.
God I,
yeah,
that was a let down.
It's like watching like a straight to
DVD sequel.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
I mean,
well gee ways.
I feel like I've done this exact meal
when I was five.
Right.
Take us hot dog,
cut in half and put some cheese on it.
So there you have it.
Salt Bay in the flesh.
And one more that I thought was pretty
insane.
I'll share with you from [inaudible]
Selfie.
He has what appears
to be a
beef mince.
It seems like he's doing some big
technical,
oh,
come on Friday.
Actually I heard,
I read an article that he wears a diaper
because he comes in his pants 10 times a
day when he cuts me.
I think neo fought him in the second
major.
Yeah,
you're right.
You're right about that.
So here he goes,
you know,
and now after searing it eat uh,
roles or the roles it and gold flakes,
gold flake.
Right.
Really that's,
those are gold flake.
The purpose of that,
I have no idea.
And it does as far as I can go.
Gold,
gold medal,
the precious metal.
Yes Dan.
But it's of all,
yeah,
I don't think I've seen gold flake
dishes.
It's much less than it appears and oh,
he was classic move there again.
I'm just like,
just like mortal combat the body.
So you know the other guy makes him look
like a tool.
Yeah,
exactly.
No comparison.
Yeah.
So there you have it.
Turkish cuisine.
I had no idea.
It's fascinating.
Stuff went that deep.
So,
um,
it's all ways also Turkish,
big,
big.
I say those are the two big boys in
Turkish,
Turkish.
But what's funny if you get into this
rabbit hole is that you'll find a bunch
of knock offs who are doing so bad
content trying to catch up with these
guys.
I was like guys who were just making a
falafel,
but they're trying to dance and be sexy
and it has like 20,000
views,
but it's just,
it's great.
And they're trying to do this smile,
like he's just making falafels and he's
got a big smile.
Great Turkish food on instagram.
Interesting.
Okay.
So there you have it.
There is the segments xtrordinair up
next in has got something far.
Should we take a break?
We're at three 30 oh yeah.
So after the short break,
very short break in is going to grace us
with people falling off stage
celebrities.
So we have a whole segment of
celebrities falling off stage during
their performances.
Is that correct Ian?
We've got a few of those.
Hell yeah.
I'm very much looking forward to that.
Sounds like a black,
they'll do not go away.
We will be right back after this short
commercial break.
Skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of classes and
design business technology and more.
You've got premium memberships that give
you unlimited access to high quality
classes on must know topics so you can
improve your skills,
unlock new opportunities.
And do the work you love.
Now,
many people play video games and they
grind and grind and grind to get the
highest level possible.
But did you know you can do that in real
life?
You can grind and work on yourself and
you can level up.
And that's what skill shares all about.
They've got classes on every fricking
thing they've got for,
for Mike Situation,
adobe suites after effects,
Premiere Lighting,
Dslr cinematography.
So if you want to make videos,
you want to be a Youtuber,
they've got everything you need,
they get started.
And then on the other hand,
and they've got like entrepreneur
classes,
they've got photography classes,
everything.
I'm telling you,
you're gonna level up with skill share.
And here's the deal.
You can get an annual subscription for
less than $10 a month.
My Dude's,
since skillshare is sponsoring this
video,
the first 500 people to use the promo
link in the description,
we'll get their first two months free to
try it out,
risk free.
So hurry on down to the description and
click the link.
S,
k,
I,
l.
Dot.
S h slash h.
Three podcasts.
That's skl dot s h slash h three
podcasts,
and the first 500 people.
To use the Promo Code,
get first two free months free.
Skl Dot s h slash h three podcast.
And we also have,
as you may notice,
these beautiful lush Christmas sweater.
Show it off Ula.
That's right.
Work it girl.
Mm.
We've got the classic they Nicholas
Design and introducing.
As you'll see on our lovely model,
Ila,
always watching a face tat Santa
Drinking,
a soda pop and got h three tatted on his
knucks.
All these sweaters come in green,
red and gray over at represent.com/h
three h three.
We also have the one meme one God,
Virgin Ila sweater.
A.
Here's the graphic.
There's only nine days left.
Nine days left guys.
Limited run.
Yeah,
that's ilow wished shredder,
the actual virgin burst.
So here you go.
Head on over to represent.com/h
three h three and finally we are having
a teddy fresh black Friday sale.
Um,
all kinds of summer stuff is on sale.
Now look at all this stuff up to 50%
off.
Head on over to teddy
fresh.com/collection/sale.
We've got to do something about that
url.
You can't change that,
huh?
Shopify,
teddy,
fresh.com/collection/sell.
But you can just go to the website and
click the sales tab.
Hey,
we're back.
How did you do that?
Okay,
I was wondering how Dan knew we were
coming back.
Just not that good.
We are back.
Everybody know mean left behind yet it
is your duty to,
uh,
save a meme.
I don't remember who kicked off the
stage.
Falling one ditch was the,
I think the genesis may have been Kelsey
grammer.
It's going to play it from here.
Well,
I'm on the,
we have audio from that lap.
Let's switch here.
Yeah,
I should do it on,
up in here.
No problem.
I think the genesis was Kelsey grammar.
We had put that video in the,
the uh,
God Vevo and the God vapor.
Okay,
well I've got that one here.
So let me,
let me grab that here.
Cause I don't believe we ever actually,
she set this up with a little bit with
some context.
Yeah.
So he,
uh,
he was doing a speech at a Disney
Disneyland I think or just,
yeah,
wait,
it was Disney.
Yeah.
Or he was at California adventure.
All bad things happen at small world.
I just love,
I love it.
So
it's one of the best,
the good Lord Ward backdrop.
He's pretty defeated about that.
I,
I've often wondered,
you know,
there's this gag and family guy where
Peter holds his leg and he goes,
ah,
forever.
I've wondered if this was in some way
inspired by this clip because he kind of
does that here.
Yeah.
When did this is,
this looks like a really,
yeah,
there's like 10 people to see if he's
okay.
Lomo and,
Oh,
good lord and oops.
Yeah.
I,
I didn't realize I was digging around in
Kelsey grammer's had a very rough life
se yes.
Like very dark.
Really like what his father was
murdered.
Oh,
whoa.
And his sister was murdered.
Why separate account?
Separate Times.
Random random murders.
Uh,
it was,
um,
I think his father was targeted by
someone.
I read that,
but then his sister was,
uh,
she was attacked by it by four guys.
And,
uh,
they,
they stabbed her and left her to die.
Oh.
And then both of his half brothers died
in a scuba diving accident.
Yeah.
His whole family perished.
I mean,
yeah.
All in different times of years apart.
That is,
that is unbelievably tragic.
I wouldn't leave the house if I was him.
And then there was a,
where he has fallen off the stage.
Yeah.
This is his first time.
There was a weird coincidence where the,
the name of the guy who killed his
father,
whose last name was niles,
which is the name of his,
oh,
the brother and brother and frazier.
And then the name of the guy who killed
his sister.
His name was,
um,
was Freddy,
uh,
and his son's name and frazier's Freddy.
So like,
it's just the two close characters.
10 minute frasier are named after.
Is that a proof that we're in a
simulation or I don't know the word
conspiracy to kill the interesting
thing.
Well,
that is very tragic.
Thank you,
man.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
serious like,
Gee Whiz.
Yeah.
That's how you can just go through your
life.
Like take my life,
for example.
Everything's great.
Just,
you know,
we're married,
you can have it.
We're about to have a baby and then one
day you could just be stabbed and it's
like,
you know,
that's it.
And then you can also be avenue speech
and fall off the stage.
I mean,
anything could happen.
Was those two things were about on the
same level.
Yeah.
Here's another one that we had at
woodside.
Madonna.
Uh,
this was at the Brit awards a few years
ago.
Yeah.
So what happened here?
I guess they came up with the feds to
come on.
I caught on someone's horn or something.
Apparently she was supposed to take the
cape off earlier,
but it was tied too tightly and she
couldn't get it off.
Wardrobe malfunction.
Yeah.
Let's see that one again.
Yeah,
that was,
that was quite,
the tumble there does not mean she knew
it was coming.
Oh,
it's the trying to get it off right.
Somebody pulled in,
someone yanked her ass off the stage.
But the answers are all pros.
They just like keep going.
I think one of them may have been trying
to help her get it off.
Oh.
And he yanked her ass off the stage.
Yeah.
Cause he gave it up really good tug and
he was like,
Oh fuck this kid.
Yeah.
She,
uh,
she responded to it.
She tweeted and said,
Armani hooked me up.
My Beautiful Cape was tied to tight.
Nothing can stop me.
And love really lifted me up.
Zach,
I heard you scream me out right from the
back.
Come on.
She's like a mega fall there.
Nothing can bring her down.
What did she say?
She said,
well,
uh,
love lifted me up.
Love lifted her up.
Sac.
Are you rebooting that and that?
Absolutely.
Here's a bieber one
or trying to fix his pants and I didn't
see a massive hole of a lot of old shit.
Fucking giant.
You set that up.
So yeah,
he probably should have spotted that.
It's pretty big hole.
I don't know.
First of all,
who is managing the stage and leaves a
giant hole in it.
I don't blame Biba.
Really?
Yeah.
No,
that'd be probably one of those where
you're like,
show up from the hole,
but they should still cover it.
Oh yeah.
No.
Somebody got fired that night.
Justin seems to be wearing 20 layers of
clothing because I don't blame him for
not being able to react.
It's chilly and those big,
don't we see that again?
That was really good.
Okay.
Oh my God.
It's like a disappearing act.
This Justin Bieber or David Blaine.
See Ya.
You know,
I,
I feel bad for the biebs.
He gets a lot of crap from everyone
trying to do his thing and he's just
falling through holes and get right out
there.
Any more information about that?
I'm fascinated by that one.
Uh,
he,
he tweeted out the video and was just
like,
I'm a cat.
I've got nine lives.
Lol.
Okay.
There's a real like,
that's like music.
He did a little added.
Yeah.
That's what you gotta do.
You just own it.
Yeah.
Are you,
uh,
are you big or you be blubber?
Oh,
we've talked,
we've,
we've got into it.
Yeah.
Bugatti.
Biebs.
He's the best.
Yeah.
Are you a fan of him?
I like him.
I think he's got,
I like his music.
I saw him on stage with post Malone and
I thought he was great.
Everyone seemed to really like it.
Yeah.
He's super tiny.
He's got a great voice and he's got
grace under the,
when he,
he's got grace,
you know,
I watched videos of the Paparazzi
hassling him and it get,
and it does give me a tremendous amount
of compassion for him and all the stupid
things he's done.
He's under a lot of pressure or pressure
and expectation and he's always been
like the guy,
he's so famous,
like he's just trying to go outside and
live his life and TMC lit in the end
and,
and Paparazzi,
just obsessive.
We followed this guy trying to push his
buttons and have been for years.
I mean,
oh,
has like a child star,
right?
Yeah.
He's been famous for considering the age
where this all happened to him.
The stuff he's done that people don't
like him for his,
I don't think it's,
you know,
that severe,
he's just like a kid making some
mistakes.
But what has he done that people are
very upset about?
He liked peed and you'd like Pete in a
bucket or something.
So big deal.
What else?
He said,
uh,
I man,
you know,
yeah.
Oh,
he was at the ransom lady over.
Remember that video?
He was like,
I'm looking up Razzi that was trying to,
there was a little too close to his car.
Maybe you ran someone over.
He got out,
he went to like the Anne Frank Memorial.
And so he would have been a believer.
That was the day one.
That was the big one.
But that's just,
you know,
in retrospect it would have been,
yeah.
Yeah.
He's like,
listen,
if I was a little younger and I was born
in the forties,
I'd have fucked and frank.
Uh,
so then this is one of my favorites.
I,
I love this video so much.
Oh.
And then I got a couple angles here I
got to bring up.
This is Travis Scott.
Drake's a boy meets world tour and
there's another situation,
these big holes in the ground.
Big problem.
Big holds,
big problems.
His mic is auto tuned.
Oh my God.
What's in the halls?
And then,
yeah,
we,
some days have a trap door like that.
But yeah,
obviously somebody fucked up.
We had open now did he fall off the
stage or in a hole?
I can't tell if he fell off something or
in something.
If there's a kilo in the middle.
Yeah,
yeah,
it's another wow.
He really,
and so the fact that you can auto tune a
fall,
it goes to show you how hard over time
these auto tunes go working.
Yeah.
And then drake cause like that's turn,
he tries to come help him.
Wait,
is that is she was an angel that looks
really bad.
Well he
actually did a lot of damage,
uh,
when he fell in that whole really what
happened actually,
well he made a statement.
Someone asked him about it.
He said,
I didn't fall,
dude.
I flew,
I was floating.
I don't fall.
Oh come on.
Nothing happened.
Floating is amazing.
And he said,
I'm a magician.
Like David Blaine disappeared.
You know,
we called it a,
but actually the,
the um,
let's see.
This is what they keep in that whole,
uh,
it's like this big globe that death was
in the hole.
They come,
they like comes out of it and inflatable
globe thing that drake would perform
with and uh,
he fell on it and smash the shit out of
it.
And Drake did this whole show for free.
He had to refund.
He refunded everybody.
Yeah.
Cause that's like such a big piece of
the show.
So for the globe was out right?
The globe with the right fricking that,
oh,
that was,
how much do you think that would have
cost?
I mean,
I don't know.
Close to an alien because that's a bit,
it was like a huge arena in London o two
arena,
right?
Yeah.
That's like one of the huge ones and
probably Amelie.
Yeah.
That Paul Costello.
Oh yeah,
I flew up.
Boy,
I wonder if he still got paid.
Travis Scott.
I don't know.
I mean drake probably wanting to make
them fly a little bit.
Uh,
let's see.
Do we have a oh yeah.
And then I think this is one that you
put in here.
This is a,
it was you,
you Miguel,
uh Oh.
This is the billboard music awards.
This one deserves to be slow mode
though.
Well,
that's why she wants more.
Miguel kicks to girls in the face is
what it's called.
And he attempts to jump over the crowd
and what he ends up doing is it wwf
crotch slam
on a four girl space.
Now let's watch it and almost feeding
and backs Loma over.
And Simon,
this is really something here.
You'll notice as she sustained a life
changing injury and then he gets close
with the girl who didn't even get body.
He hugs.
I got hurt as a way.
It's like,
all right,
well we're out of here.
Go.
Yeah,
let's go slow on this because this is a
really special moment.
MMM,
let's go court.
Yeah,
there you go.
Let's see.
Fast forward.
There you go.
Quarter,
quarter speed in corridor.
Yeah,
go ultra slow here.
So here we have a
this faith,
I'm not sure why he thought this was
great at wwf and body.
What a pro.
You'll notice that she falls to the
ground and associated with the dark
hair,
the dark hair right here.
Then the blonde girl girls like his
music sounds even better.
And apparently I found this article
where they said he was told not to do
the jump.
He asked him before if he could and they
were like,
don't do it.
And he went for it anyway.
And was there any consequence of that
while they,
Felipe?
I actually,
I found this was immediately after
backstage.
He brought the girl that hit the deck
backstage to apologize
and then he did an interview with it.
Obviously there's a little bit of a,
you know,
you give it your all when you're onstage
icing her elbow.
No,
no,
no.
What happened?
Unfortunately we met under not the best
circumstances trying to quarter,
I'm not sure.
Like this is a setup for a day,
not the best circumstances.
They'll just kick you in the head
what happened?
No,
no,
no.
He's like,
you know what happened?
no,
no.
It's Brown.
Raj slammed her to this day.
Yeah.
She really,
really got the brunt of it.
I see.
It's your elbow,
so you're still going to live dance to
Miguel zones.
Where you a big fan of Miguel?
I'm gonna put you on the spot where you,
big fan of Miguel before he,
before he jumps on,
you know him and you still adored him
even though even though you've got a
nice size yeah.
Fan of change isn't it?
Apparently she,
uh,
went to the hospital not long after that
and uh,
she said,
uh,
she said that she was having some memory
issues and stuff.
Oh my goodness.
But then her elbow.
Yeah.
And then two,
well,
two years after this happened,
the other girl that got hit actually did
sue him.
Did she win?
I couldn't find any.
Uh,
yeah,
that was settle on something like that,
you know,
is,
is it a little messed up how they like
parade her around afterwards?
Like,
oh yeah,
she just hit her up or her elbows a
little bit.
I mean,
she may have on a level been excited.
Like if she really was a fan,
it's like,
okay,
I'll use this as an opportunity to get
to meet my idol or whatever.
But um,
but yeah,
he was definitely keeping it ambiguous
for legal reasons as scripture.
Well,
that's what her representation,
he was like,
instead of taking her to get her checked
out,
you brought her to go do a quick
interview.
He was like that,
you know,
we don't really appreciate that.
Well,
God flows terrific stuff.
And that was the last of the stage
falls.
What?
It shouldn't be as funny as it is to
watch people follow this.
Yeah.
Is it just,
it's great because it's,
well,
watching someone fall just by itself is
already great.
Right.
But then when you see like a famous
person,
like these idols that people look up to
that are like untouchable larger than
life falling through a hole in the stage
contrast shot of mine to I believe is,
yeah.
It's humanizing,
I guess in a way.
Just see that they're just people they
eat shit.
Some things.
Can you remember any bad falls you had
in front of people that were
embarrassing or,
hmm.
Because I fell down a flight of stairs
at school once.
Yeah.
In front of a lot of other,
took a lot of times.
Tell me about the fall.
Yeah.
Well,
it was like,
it was,
it was very,
uh,
it was very icy outside and a lot of
snow so everyone was tracking in a,
you know,
snow and it was very slippery and I just
down the whole thing,
you know,
on my ass and there were a lot of people
around.
So that was,
you were embarrassed.
Yeah.
You carry trauma from it,
do you think?
Yeah,
I'm still emotionally scarred.
I can't go up a flight of stairs.
I mean seriously.
Was it that,
was it a real,
it's just,
you know,
when you're in high school everything's
even like feel like everyone's just
hyper aware of what you're doing.
Where you injured?
No,
no I was not injured.
Is there anyone that you cared about
that witnessed it?
Like a friend or a girl you were
interested in?
No,
they were friends route obviously get
roasted a lot.
I was like that my,
the only one that fell and had a bad
phone call civic like traumatic incident
anyways,
it wasn't like embarrassing,
but like my,
we were on those trips where they take
the whole class like at the end of the
year and um,
we were in this one like keep with,
so I don't know what it was,
but there was someone who had like a
little cart pulling like a little open
card.
I don't know,
like something on wheels you could stand
on.
And for some reason the whole class
decided to go on it.
I don't even remember how it happened,
but we all went and stood on this thing
while this is a guy who was driving this
little card and then he decided to take
it turn and I fell.
You fell off.
Just me.
Kept going.
It didn't realize any,
almost like went over my head
stop right there and roasted by your
classmates.
I was more like,
I got in trouble because we weren't
supposed to do that.
Oh.
And uh,
I dunno,
I'm not quite sure.
I have an image in my head of what
happened,
like Kinda was a car with a cart and you
all got in the back of the room.
Good little car and like meaning like a
golf cart or something like that.
Yeah.
And you were in the golf cart
so he was carrying a thing on the back.
Oh,
okay.
So it was kind of like an open,
how many people were on it?
Like 30
and you're the only one that ain't shit.
It's
so much worse.
And you don't blow really hard.
Yeah,
it was pretty bad.
Oh,
I'm glad you survived out.
Jesus.
I was just had a memory of something
really embarrassing.
They did.
I didn't fall,
but the best second remembers,
I was super into yo-yoing.
I was smoking.
I was so insane.
I was at the leap in it.
I was cribbing it.
And of course my favorite and most
impressive around the world,
the classic,
you go around the world,
you're still spending,
you're still slamming.
And so I was going at the grocery store
with my friend and we were just doing
Yoyo with his friend.
The friend,
their parents was grocery shopping and
I'm doing around the world around the
world having a good time and there's an
old lady that I fucking be here that was
stolen I guess like that.
And I didn't see her.
She crept up on me.
Is it slow and quiet?
And I hit it right in the glasses and
her glasses fell off.
Whoops.
You sent her around the world and uh,
was that the x sprain?
I seem to remember that being like the
cool one.
I don't remember,
but it was one of the good ones.
Yeah.
Sick has bearings.
Does it,
did your school try and people were
always coming to my school and trying to
sell me Yoyos yeah.
The thing that,
did you have that like Jojo salesman,
Gabon?
No,
my school outlawed Yoyos cause they were
being used at like,
but a variant that Lincoln Jojos at each
other.
But the lady she did,
um,
she did,
she passed on,
she was fine.
She just yelled at me and I was super
superman
by the way,
my story,
it ended up also even in an article in a
local newspaper.
What was the headline?
And that was the first time I learned
that the media lies because they made up
this whole thing about had the driver
was telling us not to go on the thing
and he didn't and it must have been a
slow news day.
Yeah.
Oh,
what was the headline?
Some kid falls off a thing
that you were the sub.
Wow.
Way that article.
Huh?
So you have it in Israel,
you saved it like your parents think
about that.
I tried to make it seem like less than
it was because I didn't want to get in
trouble,
but we were like a way in in northern
area so my parents couldn't like come
and see me or anything.
They called your parents to teach her.
They called my mom and I was like,
don't tell dad like it's nothing
serious.
And when you got back home where you in
deep shit?
No,
I think my mom,
she kept it.
She,
I think I managed to make it seem like
not much happened.
Mom saved your ass
and looking back really not much
happened but I felt like I was going to
get in trouble.
Yeah.
When you're a kid that's like,
oh yeah,
come on.
There you have it.
That's a credible,
what's next on the docket?
That was it.
The next one is uh,
you live segment,
I believe Isla segments.
So what should we do?
Should we do a little bit variable?
A ring around the Rosie,
although I guess you're there but you're
going to throw it on the screen.
No.
Oh,
she can do it from here down.
All right,
we got this.
There's no expectation here.
No Man left behind.
Guys,
you know,
one thing with the falling and this is,
this is a bit of a confession,
but like this isn't like a public
embarrassment thing.
This is more my own shame when I'm alone
and I'm going up the stairs.
I have like this weird tendency where I
always try and do it too fast and I
like,
I eat shit on the stairs often but never
like I keep it under wraps if I'm like
with other people.
Yeah,
exactly.
Like I don't know why,
but I am always like,
you know when I get home or something
coming up the stairs of my apartment
building,
I'll be like two stepping it up and
just,
just full on,
just flat on my face.
It's happened countless.
You think this is a problem?
I mean,
it's kind of a problem.
Like it,
it's consistent enough that I'm aware
that it's like a thing that I eat shit
on.
So why is it that you just don't slow
down?
Don't know,
man.
It's something wrong with me because
again,
if there's somebody else around,
you know,
I'm not doing that.
You're not dealing that only by herself.
And have you ever seriously injured
yourself?
I mean,
not seriously,
no.
But it bash,
bash my elbow pretty fucking hard.
Yeah.
Is it a thrill seeking I guess,
or I'm just a,
I'm always like extreme.
Like can I do it?
How many stairs can I do at once?
Whatever.
It's such a like little kid thing.
It's embarrassed.
See,
I'm getting too fat and that is shaped
that I have trouble on stairs.
Just the one step is step one step is
thrill seeking all the thrills thinking
I need.
Are we having issues?
Well guys,
as we've says,
aided no means shall be left behind.
We are behind enemy lines.
We are doing technical fixes.
Okay.
There you go.
Sorry.
Okay.
I want,
I was trying to save it.
All right.
Eli,
what is your segment once you got,
we miss this next story is one of my
favorite stories.
Oh yes.
And corporate executive let us sacred
devil life as an Australian poo jogger.
And what happened is that this guy,
the Washington Post democracy dies in
darkness.
Yeah.
Guy Was,
he had like a nice job.
I'm sorry,
this is not used to the wwe was actually
on the city council
inclusivity board,
which was oh yeah.
You have this bullet point thing here.
Yeah.
And,
um,
so I don't know how to do this because I
can't read it from the article you had
just read from this.
Okay.
So he was served on the city council,
which made recommendations about how the
city should grow.
And he had a pretty high up job.
He's a well respected member of the
community.
Yeah.
But in an unflattering picture on a
public sidewalk and Australia,
he recently was discovered as
the infamous doing who jogger stage.
That's too perfect.
So I think the story is
not stage.
The guy that took this picture actually
was planning it for like a year because
they kept getting this like human shit
on this street
and it was like not even,
it was clear that it wasn't an accident
cause sometimes you would even like
toilet paper and next to them he left,
he brought to the paper with him.
He went there to get outside.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's bless.
Pre murder.
Premeditated kidding.
And so over time the people that leave
them,
that area we're trying to figure out
like when he was doing it to find the
schedule is something and then they were
trying to get a picture of him so they
could reveal who it was and it took them
about a year until they figured out and
like the time that it was usually doing
it and then they left.
They tried living like caroline has in
the area.
I want to see a documentary and
eventually this guy was waiting for him
with the camera and when he was about to
snap the picture there was like a red
dot on the camera and he saw it and
looked and that's when he took the
picture.
This is like a true crime.
Documentaries and what's the show
that's like a parody of this scandal or
whatever?
Her vandal vandal.
Yeah.
It almost seems straight out of that.
Totally.
Did he like,
was it targeted?
Was He trying to pool on specific
peoples neighborhood,
like your doors or he was just,
he just had like a weird thing outside
or something real.
Can you see it as nuts or what?
No,
I don't.
I don't think cause yeah,
it probably just assume.
Let's just say no,
it's his other leg now.
Yeah.
I don't think he can see his nuts,
but there's,
I mean that's,
there's a lot going on there that you
can't see.
God the picture so good.
His name is Andrew Mackintosh.
If you're an audio listener,
you need to go google this immediately.
So,
um,
what's the,
what was the result of this
investigation?
Through take a picture.
He looks at him and just said,
hello.
Wait,
who said hello?
The pooper hello.
Poo jogger.
And then once this was released,
they like,
it became viral and everyone knew it was
him and he was charged with a fine of
$378.
Oh,
that's a small press brake light.
He lost his job.
Okay.
There's a bomber.
It was an executive,
you said,
right?
He was on the city council.
Public Servant.
Now it looks like I just googled,
his name is,
he's a corporate executive and on the
city council,
very upstanding in like every way.
Such a perfect story,
isn't it?
God,
what do you,
where do you go from there to the
sidewalk to let me know?
There's one great to wade that someone
made a jogger footage narrated by Devin
Davion national board.
Is there a video or just a,
no,
just the photo today.
You could see as the Australian puzzle
jog,
it comes out at 3:00
AM and shits on his neighbors grass.
No one has found him and the wild until
now.
That that's beautiful thing.
That's it.
There you have it.
Yellow,
uh,
well,
very well described the poo jogger.
Um,
we are coming right along here on no
means left behind.
And we are certainly not least any of
our Congress.
The time certainly should not have been
left behind cause that and it hasn't,
that was amazed.
Not Anymore.
You're up next with the wacky and wild
world of a world record.
Okay.
Yeah.
So,
so yeah,
w somehow this,
uh,
slipped through the cracks,
but even before looking for content for
the show,
I'm just like weird ass world records
has always been really interesting to
me.
People that like,
you know,
demonstrate some bizarre fucking skill.
Um,
so there's,
this is all going to build up to
something,
but we'll,
we'll start a little slow.
So this was a relatively recently,
it's got Eli Bishop held the world
record for a number of claps in a
minute.
It's exciting.
Yeah.
You can clap.
It's called speed clapping and
apparently there's like this whole
subculture.
Well,
this is the current champion is a nine
year old.
Whoa.
This guy who has dedicated his life to
it.
Uh,
Mr Eli Bishop,
he's like in his thirties or something,
owned by a nine year old.
So yeah.
Here's,
here's poor Eli.
I'm not no,
get the hell out of here.
Facebook.
Wow.
Yeah.
So this is actually kind of cool
clapping.
Yeah.
I find that they shoot it in high speed
so they can actually count each
individual cow,
uh,
slowed down.
Yeah.
Within 60 seconds I was able to clap 120
times.
I'm like,
he's beating off super fast.
Yeah.
It's kind of,
if you don't know what you're hearing,
it's a little,
it's a little odd.
A hundred or a thousand cars.
1024 live here.
I'm going to swelled records.
We're here.
Nobody cares about this guy.
He's not the world record anymore
because this kid,
this fucking nine year old,
a nine year old saw that video and was
like,
wait,
I can do that.
Fuck that.
Guttery yeah,
just fucking dumb.
Whoa
sky.
Okay,
good idea.
We give this guy,
that guy's like,
this is all I have is all I have.
Which that's,
that's like the flip side to it is like
these people that have these odd skills.
Wait,
this kid's name is seven kid's name.
It's seven ways.
Yup.
Seinfeld joke.
Yeah.
Wait,
what was,
is that dirt?
Yeah,
sorry.
Yeah.
Way.
You know,
I was thinking about naming our first
daughter Soda because I always thought
that was a cute name.
There's an episode of Seinfeld where
George wants to name his kids seven and
soda.
Know what happens tomorrow.
One of them steal seven,
his cousin's still seven and this must
have been inspired by by,
I didn't even think about that.
Seven.
Well,
no wonder he's such a superstars.
Parents are Seinfeld fans,
good rocks.
And yeah,
he got beat up by a faster though,
if I can say that.
Yeah.
But,
uh,
evidently this,
they counted this and he did a 1080,
so 60 more claps in a second.
It's a clap.
Well,
they,
they're doing some kind of,
it counts like each percussion of it as
an individual.
Think he's hitting like there's lower.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well,
everyone at home,
you want to,
your path to stardom is very clear,
very simple.
You just,
all you gotta do is on there you have
it.
I mean,
that one's pretty straight forward,
but now we'll get into the,
to the hardship.
Mm.
So,
um,
this guy guerard Dani,
now he evidently has since broken the
record since this video I'm about to
show you,
but there is no,
there's no video of it.
It was a guinness verified thing,
but
there is apparently a record that
exists.
He's a dream diocese.
It was on a German television show.
We did it most number of plungers stuck
to someone's back.
Why?
Why is that even a category?
Right?
And so this is where it starts to get,
like,
this is the beginning of the gate.
Farnam here.
You,
sorry,
I'm sorry.
So record.
Right.
And that's the thing.
Not only is there a record for this,
but the record in 60 seconds,
which I guess this is more of just a
demonstration,
but this guy does have the record and
the record is 15.
So bossy,
not even like a lot,
right.
Money.
He just throwing shit at these poor
guys.
I love it.
They're all in jeans flex and everybody
reads once I got to say this is one of
the weirdest things I've ever seen.
Yeah.
This is uh,
this is definitely a fetish.
Like their hot little twinks and they're
all in jeans and they're all wearing
motorcycle helmets.
We got to do it safely.
Boom.
There it is.
Really exciting.
Yeah.
This,
this is uh,
this is the,
uh,
the kind of stuff that um,
you can go down in history for.
I wonder how you practice for that.
Like do you call like your friends and
be like,
I need you for a second.
Yeah.
I,
interesting Gig craigslist.
Interesting Gig for an afternoon.
Right?
50 bucks.
So I need you to wear these jeans,
dad jeans and span populates.
Why throw punches at you?
Cool.
I'm into that,
nope.
Here's the real shit.
You know what I want?
How do these categories come into
existence?
I know the Guinness World Record,
it has all these categories of feats
that you can achieve,
but how does something like throwing a
plunger out to dude,
I thought was that able to just pitch it
to them?
Honestly,
can you rate your own records?
There is an extraordinary thing I can
throw plungers that people make it stick
to them.
And a,
you shouldn't be really like an ethnic
person to like pursue something so
weird,
but make it a Guinness record,
right?
Like,
well,
it's making me think,
I wonder if I have any,
that's where the talents that just
haven't been pitched to them yet.
Right,
exactly.
Times masturbated in one day.
I wonder if that is a Guinness World
Record,
you know?
Hmm.
I'm going to look.
Probably,
probably so I think I may be the,
they're like 30.
I was like,
Ugh,
I'd beat that.
I'm at 50 these days.
So,
um,
this one now what I found out is that
there's actually competing record
organization.
Guinness is the famous one of course.
Um,
but there's also record setter.
Apparently a competitor.
Right?
A competitor.
Now this guy is the guy from the
Philippines.
He set the record for the most lit
candles extinguished by a fart lit.
Whoa.
Okay.
Yeah.
Which again,
it's like,
I feel like somebody could do better.
Somebody out there in the audience.
You can,
you could totally one up this even a
smile.
This is serious business.
Did I do it?
Yo Yo Yo,
is this not just like expert village
where you could just send that?
Maybe y'all can I watch that again?
We got to roll that back.
So the guys on his back and he's got
like a horn,
like a horn up to his asshole and he's
doing power farts on five lit candles
and blowing them out of a time.
Boom.
That sound is something in it.
Definitely.
You're finished.
Yeah,
I'm in.
Good God.
I come on my pants every time I hear it
because seriously is basis.
So all of his ration.
Yeah.
He's holding his sack by the way.
Got a hand on his showed.
I don't know what that does,
but I'm sure it's part of his
superpowers.
Go get the right angle.
I like that.
It's just like what?
That's incredible.
I have got 10 weird sex records.
Dan,
would you like to hear them?
Yeah,
let's hear it.
This is part two though.
I'm not got a good Paul here.
Furthest ejaculation.
Woe is 19 feet longer than a stretch
limo.
What?
19 feet?
18 feet.
Nine inches.
Now that's a record.
Yeah,
both orgasms in one hour.
Here's the one that I was going for.
A record is a woman who had 134 over the
course of our record for males.
Just 16.
Hmm.
Huh?
How do you even verify that?
Who's verifying?
Yeah.
Well I've heard of women who have a
disease where they,
it's actually like a psychological
problem where they can't stop.
Orgasming it seems like torture for
them.
But a 16 is the physical with a guy,
you know,
you got a little something proven.
It actually can monitor heart rate and
think,
oh,
maybe they just thought this through.
Well for Guinness World Record,
you get very seriously.
Um,
what else?
You got?
16.
I feel like I could give that a run.
That's the,
an hour 16 in an hour.
I mean,
that's one every,
that's pretty quick.
That's a lot.
Five minutes or something.
I mean,
if you think you're up to the pit like
10 and you die in an hour's pretty fuck,
well your Dick just becomes like super
numb.
Who'd of all life?
16.
Huh?
Honorable Mention is the official
longest orgasm was recorded in 1966 when
a woman had a 45 second orgasm that
involve 25 individual contractions.
Oh.
So the contractions is probably,
they're able to monitor to that maybe
man,
who fathered the most children?
69 kids.
Uh Oh.
Oh,
Mrs vast Sylvia is pregnancy prowess
pales in comparison in the multiplying.
Could you just read there's like a
normal person the king of Morocco had
between,
uh,
over his lifespan,
the king of Morocco fathered at least
114 children,
surely.
Gangas con probably.
Okay.
Whatever.
This stopped being interesting.
Go ahead Dan.
Okay.
All right.
So this all leads me to,
um,
some of my favorite videos I've,
I've seen on the internet in a long
time.
Um,
so this is actually very recent,
um,
back in September of this year,
this guy in India,
um,
his name is Navin Kumar,
broke the world record for the most
number of walnuts smashed with your
forehead and other really competitive,
well let me tell you,
I got news.
It is very competitive.
There are a lot of guys facing this one.
Yes.
So,
so the previous record,
um,
he broke this guy did a 217 and he broke
the previous record by 36.
Um,
so smashed,
smashed it literally,
literally fast.
Wow.
This is super superpower.
Those nuts are really,
you've got to go on it.
It's no joke.
And at the end of this video,
you'll see,
I mean his,
his forehead is like,
oh no.
Like they're not be good.
Well,
you know,
nfl players have like brain damage.
The shiny like this is a story about
that on 60 minutes.
So Megan's smashing your head into a
walnut,
like a thousand accounts.
Well,
it's worth it for the glory.
I guess.
The grunts are really what makes it
good.
You don't have to do this.
If you're like,
you lost some speed on that turn there.
Really shouldn't.
They got get a longer table.
You don't have to do this man yelling.
Right.
You could do it.
That was a minute.
Didn't quite make it the whole way,
but shake his hand.
Oh yeah.
Wow.
It's all very calm.
Don't imagine going
through all of that TV camera there.
Yeah,
I mean,
again,
this was there and everything like this
was all this was sanctioned.
Um,
now imagine going through all of that.
Only to have one month later.
Oh No,
this is super competitive.
This is a,
this guy's name is Mohammad old.
She didn't seem we should maybe have
joey cells try to crack walnuts.
Oh,
for the charity.
Like every one that he cracks his like,
uh,
it's like more money that will don't do
too.
Yeah,
but it's amazing.
That'll be so good.
Maybe that's good one.
I'll see if he's
down.
We can ask him anything.
You're utterly,
he really is.
He's,
especially for the sake of charity.
I mean he's got a sweetheart.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
So,
um,
so not only did,
so this guy that the previous guy,
I'm Navin,
um,
did 217 this,
this guy,
a 32 year old Mohammed Rashid Naseem um,
managed to terrible.
I can already get a fancier table and if
you thought that last guys a sound
effects,
his efforts were good.
You got here
now are these tapes to the table?
Maybe there's like a little bit of
stickiness guys.
A genuine bro.
You don't have to do this,
but these guys are practice this a lot
too.
Yeah,
you'd have to,
I guess it's core guy.
Yes.
He got the right strategy.
Any focusing his energy much,
much more strongly with that.
Oh.
Oh,
I didn't even see that.
Holy Shit.
No.
Oh,
they're all bloody now.
He's like,
oh my God.
And Guinness approved that is fucking
nuts.
He was about 150 deep and then just
suddenly every single one,
he's not stopping.
He missed.
Oh my God.
It is one where he missed the nut and
slammed his head on the table.
And there was a huge spot.
My fucking lawyer,
this guy's a warrior.
Seriously,
did he get money?
Uh,
I don't think there's any cash prize for
it's just the glory.
Glory,
the glory.
He God keep the woman luxury book.
Yeah.
Hard to watch.
I did not realize how you got that sound
effects that Oh my God,
my God,
that's really hard to watch.
Did you not notice that gruesome,
I didn't realize how gruesome that one
got.
I only discovered this one,
uh,
this morning cause I was trying to find
more info on that other one and saw the
story that that was literally less than
a month later he got completely blown
away by this guy threw a true expert
pete with that.
No,
that guy,
his,
his mind and body and how he's exist
solely to smash those nuts.
That's why I'm wondering like how do you
get rewarded this guy not cracks or
work.
Yeah.
He knows you're right.
Do not crack at work.
He's like,
Yup,
all the time.
What does he get?
I know know what was there,
what does it stand?
The descriptive book.
What's his actual Youtube Channel?
I just really,
wow.
Just has his Neri is,
can you show mark look,
feel more?
Uh,
yeah.
Let's,
let's see what he has to say about the
category forwards and argued with that.
While that was really something.
So there's a whole wide world of this
and yeah,
I dunno.
Like even though this is hilarious,
I find something really interesting
about people that choose to be excellent
at something so stupid.
You know what I mean?
Like,
yeah,
it's dumb.
But this guy is the best person on the
planet.
The wine walnuts with his forehead.
Yeah.
That would make an incredible
documentary.
Don't think people that pursue becoming
specialized,
hyper specialized in these one weird
thing.
Little niche things.
Yeah.
That would be amazing,
man.
You got to Dan,
you have a mission in life.
So I'm going to go out to a,
I think this got all,
if you guys from Pakistan,
so you can't make it whole.
And then Joey Salads to do some on,
on the scene reporting.
Yeah.
We'll have to see if he's a,
if he's good to go.
So yeah,
that's it.
That's a,
that's the wild and the world.
I was wonderful and it's world record.
Wow.
That was nuts,
ian coming in.
Scott.
Wow.
How long were you thinking of that?
Oh,
like 10 minutes.
Uh,
reporters destroying shit,
dude.
Those games books were my favorite
thing.
Yeah.
They're interested in.
That's so cool.
Wow.
How do I top the nut?
Crack should have saved that for the
end.
And I was incredible.
I'm really enjoying this very special
episode.
Eight street podcast of leaving no man
behind having a lot of fun out here.
You know,
it had to be done.
It had to be done.
That's good.
Not couldn't have happened.
It couldn't have been hidden from the
people all see a of the United States
military is to leave no man behind.
And it is our policy here on this
podcast to leave.
No mean behind it.
We didn't have a choice.
Yeah.
We didn't want to,
I didn't want to go back and then have a
choice.
Um,
so here we have,
this is something that I've been working
on and thinking about for a long time.
There are these wonderful videos of
reporters destroying shit.
Now the question that I have,
when you go deep down this rabbit hole
of these goofy reporters,
not walking into ice sculptures or
knocking over whatever aunt during live
broadcasts,
it's sick.
It's always the same guy kind of.
Well,
there is duplicates and so I'm wondering
is this fake real?
Is this because these are
old clips?
Is this viral cause if it's fake,
this guy's like a genius.
Before,
before it was a thing.
So let me get into this here.
This is the guy in question team known
worldwide for their bubble artistry is
attempting to burst the bubble world
records.
They helped to set a new Guinness record
for the most people that wow,
I meant to do that.
Reporter David is our,
is covering the bubble story from the
inside.
Yes.
This guy.
Okay.
And at an Aa on,
as you say,
we are here at the Discovery Science
Center in Santa Ana.
All things science,
entertainment,
education,
technology.
The event going on the next three weeks
here is really unbelievable.
No,
not unbelievable on believable.
And we're about to explain why all these
good folks here are getting in a giant
size bubble to try and get the Guinness
World Record.
George over here to introduce you to fan
Yang who was under sneakiness level fan.
Thank you so much for being here and
what is going on Big Ben.
This is going to be a Guinness World
Record for the most number of people
inside the bubble.
We have 150 people here,
right when the platform to be inside a
giant Bobby Rail,
right?
150 people.
So far the world record is 90 people in
a bubble to Guinness.
The judges are standing by to documents.
Yeah,
that's correct.
We have a Guinea Sport Echo Jetta right
there.
So we are ready to go.
How does one get involved in bubbles?
What is the dynamic behind all this?
Well,
this all come from my childhood.
I was fascinated by the bubbles floating
on the surface of the river when I was
six years old and then when I was 18
years,
I start to experiment.
It's various liquid solution just to
make the largest possible,
both amateurs and in both getting on is
my passion.
And today I'm the bubble artist and
bubbles scientists.
And do I understand correctly,
you've been working on this for years
and it's some sort of secret mixture,
70% water and 30% you don't like to
tell,
uh,
I have a or develop over the past 27
years old.
Come on.
Soapy solution is 70% tactical,
sent his secret ingredients.
So here as just so no mistake.
Yeah,
we cannot make a mistakes because we'd
have a one attempt and just we have to
make it right.
Cute.
Georgia this way.
I want to introduce you to Aaron Rhodes.
Erin with a discovery science center.
Thank you for being here.
You're welcome here.
And why is this important?
Obviously it's fun and festivity,
but what is the deal with science and
bubbles?
Everything we do at the science center
tries to combine science with,
I mean,
Oscar's science center.
Thank you so much.
It was very real.
I guess.
What's a do this thing now?
Fan.
Are you ready to get your world's
record?
Uh,
yes.
I'm very excited and via already to go
and we have a Guinea spot just to give
us a sign.
You've climbed a step back?
Yes.
The audience as well.
Thank you.
Okay,
so we are ready to go.
And can you just step a little bit back?
So just yet,
sorry.
I'm sorry.
Broke the bubble and they only have one
chance.
He said,
although I don't know why you would only
have one chance,
but I'm not above it.
Sorry.
Sorry about that.
Can you?
No,
it was very real life.
And we'll send it back to you.
Sorry.
Oh my God.
Big.
They're all like unbelievably good at,
yeah.
Okay.
So I have a theory,
Tim.
Hi Decker moment.
He's apologizes to the new bank.
Sorry.
Sorry about that.
Sorry I had an animal.
Send it back to you.
Sorry.
Okay,
so there you have,
it looks real.
I have a feeling it's fake.
Really like the one time only thing
seems suspicious to me now.
Why would you only be able to do it
once?
Okay.
There's an explanation on to exhibit B
and thank you for supporting me in this
pursuit.
Now go.
I'll fast forward to another reporter.
Goofs and what?
You know,
it's this same reporter,
another live broadcast with the ice
sculpture.
Okay.
How I saw that first few days I was
like,
wow,
this is incredible.
This is real.
This is real stuff.
When I saw this clip and threw
everything into question,
here we go.
Your prize possessions.
Oh yeah.
This is a Barocas Cherub.
It's,
it's actually been a very tough piece to
do.
We've been working on it for about eight
hours right now.
We still got quite a ways to go on it.
Beautiful.
Yes.
Can I take a closer look at this?
Because why is this your,
Oh,
oh my God,
I am so sorry.
So intentional.
I'm so sorry.
It was just an accident.
We'll talk to management
fake or not.
It's fucking hilarious.
I agree.
But watch his hand.
Okay.
Now he puts his hand and he seems to
really push it.
Oh my God,
I am so sorry.
I love how he puts the mic in his face,
like he get his answer.
So sorry dude,
are you serious?
I'm so sorry.
It was just an accident.
We'll talk to management.
I'm tired of guys out of here.
We'll,
we'll,
we'll get this taken care of and what
exactly anyway with a smile on my face.
So I'll send it back to you at an a on.
That's the same guy.
Same Guy.
Yeah.
So one theory that I've worked on is
that the first one was real,
second one was a fake to try to turn it
into a thing.
Oh,
that's interesting.
That's his thing,
right?
That being said,
the first one,
there seemed to be a lot more
humiliation and shame and there was so
much with all the buildup to yeah,
exactly.
And there was tons of people there.
That's just some local news channel.
So yeah,
there are a lot of moving parts.
It would be,
did you know,
it's pretty impressive.
That's a big,
a big effort.
Just for a little gag regardless.
It is fascinating.
I think what you said,
I think,
I think the original probably was real.
And then it just became his,
his signature thing to fuck shit up
cause he had,
the way he handled it the second time
was very different.
Although he is a pro at this point of
ruining things.
But now I have a bonus,
um,
a bonus clip for you all and you can
tell me if you think this one is real or
fake.
And it's another classic by the way.
I just checked and stress warrant
record.
They don't pay.
They weren't giving us,
it doesn't pay.
What does those nut guys,
they don't even cover expenses.
Oh you have to pay.
That's right.
We were trying to get again,
this person out for something we did.
What was it?
The va number of shirts.
Oh No,
the vein were to make like the biggest
vape.
Oh right.
The thing is you have to pay them to
come out.
Right.
Which I guess makes sense.
Said some of it is people look pretty
broke on it.
That's like the nuts to have table.
I don't think I was with Guinness
though.
The the not one.
No,
it was,
yeah.
They had the banner behind them.
Oh yeah,
no there were,
that was officially sanctioned.
I'm almost paid to be there.
But that being said,
we've got a really classic,
this is classic per year,
uh,
entertainment and judge we
really want to show you is right over
here.
This is the leaning tower of Pisa campus
And uh,
the person that's built is riding around
the corner here was cables wrapped
around Bryan Barney Hill.
Oh God.
1990 graduate of northern and uh,
he's gonna tell us a little bit about
this amazing structure.
Well,
as you can see the leaning tower of
Pisa,
it's about 12,000
blocks.
It took over two weekends to build and
I'm,
I'm really excited because next week,
uh,
the Guinness Book World Records Team are
going to come to evaluate it and really
looking forward to that.
What?
Hello?
I'm too much of a scratch off.
I feel like even this holds vague.
Are you about this?
He thinks,
I guess.
Yeah.
Well,
no,
I think if it's fake that they built it,
had the purpose of it though it off and
then they wanted to,
well they wanted to,
you know,
have a gag while destroying it.
Um,
but either way it's a,
it's a joy to be holding it either way.
Okay.
So what else we got here?
Um,
we've got a bunch of leftover videos and
stuff,
but everyone's done their segment.
We've saved a lot of memes here today.
We've done a service.
We've,
I feel like we all deserve a purple
heart.
Yeah.
Um,
well we did it.
We did it and that was good.
We came,
we saw,
we went to war,
we went behind enemy lines and we've
saved some really valuable or worthy
means.
Pulled them out of the shit.
Yeah,
that was special.
So thank you guys are joining us on this
special episode of a no man left behind.
We will be back on Friday as usual next
Friday.
Bill Works is here.
Very excited about that.
And,
uh,
thank you so much to the illustrious and
Ian,
of course,
who with whom to show would not be the
same without true.
Can I say that?
Yeah,
I would say that.
for sure.
So Ian,
I wanted to get back to something.
You were a fan when you joined.
Yeah.
But are you still a fan?
Do you hate me now that you've worked
with,
first of all,
when the shit hits the fan or are you
still,
I'm still a fan.
I do still enjoy it.
And you would lie to me.
Okay.
Well I have to watch every episode and I
don't hate it.
Yeah.
Okay.
I don't hate to call.
That's the best.
That's the best you can say about this
podcast.
I don't hate,
I don't hate it.
You had a year,
but she'd be the slogan.
I don't hate it.
I hate it.
I don't hate you either.
Thank you.
All right guys.
See you on Friday.
Have a great thanksgiving by the way.
Awesome.
That's true.
And um,
in fact,
I'm going to step it up in front.
Have a blessing giving.
Wow.
Continued to send this fence,
submissions,
podcasts at Atrius rubric and the Gun.
And we got some good ones.
Good.
If you guys plan on breaking a Guinness
World Record,
let us know all officiate it.
Save some money.
I'll come,
we'll cover us and all of things.
And the
uh,
the charity one,
that's 21st December 1st and I think
joey sells it and I'm going to ask if he
wants to crack some nuts with his head
cause that'd be amazing.
I'll give a shot to one.
Oh,
I think I'm going to regret that.
I don't have,
I don't think I have the will to
overcome the urge to not slam your head
into it.
Not as hard as you can.
Yeah.
And I think if you,
if you hesitate at all,
it's going to hurt way worse.
It's like breaking a board if you've
ever done that.
Like if you,
if you pull your punch at all,
you break your knuckles,
but if you just go for it,
really,
you're all good.
Yeah.
Boy.
Howdy.
I break boards all the time.
I mean,
it's no big deal.
Yeah.
Alrighty.
Um,
thank you guys for watching and we shall
see you on the next episode of Friday.
Happy thanksgiving.
Everybody.